université raymond barre se fâche il
dénonce les casseurs et les frénétiques
politique controverse sur la réforme du
code pénal
alain peyrefitte s'explique sur antenne
2 du soleil pour le week-end de
pentecôte
laurent broomhead le promet là messieurs
bonsoir les universités à la une de ce
journal en effet c'est ce dossier et lui
seul qui sera demain entre raymond barre
et françois mitterrand à l'hôtel
matignon
voilà trois ans tout juste que les deux
hommes ne se sont pas rencontrés c'était
à l'occasion du fameux face à face
télévisé
et là c'est le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste qui a sollicité cet
entretien
depuis tout à l'heure françois
mitterrand c'est à quoi s'en tenir quant
à l'attitude du premier ministre en la
matière une attitude extrêmement ferme
le gouvernement ne laissera pas renaître
le désordre dans les universités a dit
raymond barre devant les recteurs
d'académie qui l'avait convié à déjeuner
les recteurs sont les représentants de
l'état auprès des universités
leur rôle est donc de veiller à
l'application des lois et règlements les
concernant en 1968 nos universités ont
failli périr depuis elle se sont
lentement redresser a déclaré le premier
ministre pour lui l'agitation de ces
derniers mois risquent de remettre tout
en cause raymond barre a donc demandé au
recteur d'académie la plus grande
fermeté devant ces troubles qui sont dit
il le fait d'une petite minorité
il faut poursuivre cette reconstruction
si nous voulons faire de nos universités
des centres de culture de recherche et
d'influencé française aussi le
gouvernement ne laissera t-il pas
renaître le désordre dans les
universités
il ne laissera pas se dégrader leur
image de marque dans le pays et dans le
monde par une attitude de faiblesse à
l'égard de casseurs de fanatiques
politisé et d'amateurs de guérilla
urbaine
il appartiendra à la force publique
d'apporter son concours aux officiers de
police judiciaire intervenant en
flagrant délit pour faire cesser les
troubles et on arrêtait les autres au
regard de l'ordre public
l'université ne bénéficie d'aucune
franchise donc un privilège d'aucune
situation d'extraterritorialité
puis le premier ministre a justifié les
mesures envers les étudiants étrangers
les meilleurs vont dans d'autres pays at
il dit le gouvernement devait donc
modifier le recrutement dans l'intérêt
de tous je défie quiconque de démontrer
que notre procédure n'est pas légitime
et libérable qu'elle met pas conforme
aux intérêts de nos universités et aux
intérêts des étudiants étrangers eux
mais pour ces raisons je vous confirme
que les textes en vigueur seront
appliquées
vous avez le devoir de veiller à leur
application
l'autonomie des universités ne saurait
s'exercer dans le mépris des lois et
règlements et dans un sondage paris
match public la majorité des français ne
jugent pas excessive la proportion
d'étudiants d'origine étrangère mais
pour les trois quarts des personnes
interrogées les mesures gouvernementales
de restriction quant à l'inscription de
ces étudiants étrangers sont justifiées
avant de recevoir
alain peyrefitte pour un autre projet de
réforme contesté en ce moment une
parenthèse sur ce désastre écologique
aux états unis tout près des chutes du
niagara
vous le savez 700 amis ils vont devoir
en effet être évacuées parce qu'elles
étaient installés sur un véritable
dépotoir chimique des eaux
d'infiltration en effet remonter à la
surface les produits chimiques
cancérigènes
enterré voilà près de trente ans dès
aujourd'hui une commission d'audition
publique a commencé à enquêter
elle a reçu des témoignages accablants
et poignant de familles angoissées pour
l'avenir de leurs enfants
et voilà que les américains apprennent
qu'il y a chez eux trente huit dépôts de
matières chimiques ainsi que nous sommes
interrogés sur ce qui se passait en
france il n'y a pas de production de
dioxine nous a répondu le ministère de
l'environnement
de plus la france est équipé de 14
centres de désintoxication c'est donc là
que sont dirigés est très têtu voit les
produits les plus toxiques en régaler a
voulu en savoir plus voici les 14
centres français spécialisé dans le
traitement de déchets industriels
les acides provenant
galvanoplastie par conteneur
umicore organiques comme les solvants et
certains hydrocarbures sont traités ici
par incinération ou par des méthodes
physico chimiques
chaque centre est plus ou moins
spécialisés dans cette usine par exemple
on ne traite pas les cyanure qui sont
envoyées dans une autre unité ses usines
de détoxication sont placés sous la
surveillance de l'administration qui
contrôle les produits à leur arrivée et
à leur sortie
aujourd'hui on estime à 20% les déchets
industriels traité dans ces unités
spécialisées pour les 80% restants il
faut bien dire que cela dépend de la
bonne conscience des industriels qui
investissent ou non pour tt eux mêmes
leurs résidus dangereux
toutefois les produits très toxiques
passent obligatoirement par de tels
centres
ici les industriels ne leur jette plus
enfin je n'accuse pas les industriels
mais enfin je pense que il ya quelques
années ces déchets pouvaient aller
éventuellement ailleurs que dans des
centres spécialisés
et puisqu'ils viennent ici c'est qu'ils
sont traités comme vous avez pu le voir
est ce nous sommes plutôt des dépôts
leurs prêts des pollueurs
les déchets sont neutralisés sont
stockés dans des décharges comme
celle-ci réservée aux produits
industriels
deux fois par semaine des contrôleurs et
opère des prélèvements pour vérifier
leur innocuité
en fait nous avons commencé à mettre ses
centres en service à partir de 1974
auparavant un certain nombre de déchets
toxiques étaient traités par les
industriels eux mêmes dans leurs propres
installations et incinérés il est vrai
cependant que un certain nombre de
déportés qu'elle fait dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas toujours
satisfaisant ces dépôts ont été
inventoriés et ceux qui représentent des
risques potentiels mineurs mais enfin
possible son font l'objet d'un suivi à
l'aide de piézomètres pour vérifier
qu'il n'ya pas de d'extension de
pollution presque pas en france de
construire des pavillons sur des
anciennes décharges contenant des
produits toxiques
alors voyez ces dépôts sont bien connus
ils ne contiennent pas de produit aussi
toxique que la dioxine par exemple et
-aucun ou bien entendu n'a servi de
support à des lotissements voix des
constructions politiques maintenant avec
toujours les suites du sommet de
varsovie le chef de l'état a dépêché
l'un de ses collaborateurs à londres
pour rendre compte de ses entretiens
avec lénine brejnev par ailleurs la
rencontre agite toujours beaucoup les
milieux politiques lui ds bernard stasi
a soutenu aujourd'hui la démarche mais
le rpr jean louis cros qui l'a condamné
ce aplatir au pied des soviétiques n'a
jamais été gaulliste at il dit quand on
socata général du parti républicain
jacques blanc il a lui accepté le wild
et sportif français pour les jeux
olympiques à linverse de son ami michel
pont qui prône lui le boycott
deuxième sujet de polémique la sphère
poniatowski 6 argent ducret directeur la
police judiciaire confirmait que son
ministre de l'époque michel koldowski
donc ne savait rien des menaces de mort
visé jean de braye mail avait en
revanche a pris après le meurtre les
journalistes se sont alors tournés vers
le christian bonnet qui il y à un mois
avait épaulé son prédécesseur en
affirmant qu'il n'avait jamais été au
courant de ces menaces
à cause de christian benêt je réaffirme
que la hiérarchie n'a pas été tenu
informé avant le 24 décembre sans cesse
c'est à dire le jour de la mort de jean
de braye et puis troisième gros débat en
ce moment celui qui tourne autour du
projet de loi déposé par le garde des
sceaux sécurité et liberté
destiné à réformer le code pénal alors
je garde voilà un projet qui est destiné
à aller dans le sens de ce que souhaite
selon vous l'opinion publique
or tous les hommes de robe ou presque
avocats et magistrats se lève contre
votre projet alors de deux choses l'une
où il n'est pas possible de réclamer
quoi que ce soit en france ou bien vous
l'avez mal vendu mal expliqué il y avait
une troisième solution c'est vrai que en
france il est très difficile de réformer
les juristes notamment aime les
traditions et ils sont craintifs quand
ils voient des innovations auxquelles il
n'était pas habitué
et c'est un fait que allah actuelle les
organisations syndicales de magistrats
et d'avocats sont contre ce projet c'est
vrai que vous l'avez pas parié un petit
peu en catimini aussi oui mais elles ont
été de toute façon contre ce projet à
l'avance donc il valait mieux qu'elle
soit contre ce projet une fois qu'ils
auraient été déposés sinon il n'aurait
jamais été déposées en vous bien filmé
d'une roue de riz plâtre l'ajustement
les députés ont demandé aujourd'hui
qu'il est que le débat soit repoussée
d'une semaine
justement parmi ceux qui s'opposent à ce
projet il y en a qui s'opposent parce
qu'ils sont des opposants systématiques
cela je ne suis pas de les convaincre
qu'ils soient parlementaires ou qu'ils
soient magistrats ou avocats appartenant
à des organisations qui s'opposent
je ne vais pas essayer de surmonter
cette opposition là mais il y a des gens
qui sont perplexes qui se posent des
questions ils ont parfaitement le droit
de se poser des questions à propos d'un
test qui est tout à fait nouveau et par
conséquent à la demande des deux groupes
de la majorité le groupe rpr et le
groupe udf qui m'ont
monte entendu et qui m'en donner leur
appui massif à la demande également du
président de la conférence des
bâtonniers qui appuient également mon
projet mais qui tous m'ont demandé de
pouvoir l'étudier plus en détail j'ai
accepté volontiers de rallonger un peu
les délais de même de manière que toutes
les facettes de ce projet soit examinée
que toutes les objections qui sont
faites puisse trouver une réponse à
cette compétition me sens maintenant le
fond des choses et il vraiment laxisme
des juges comme vous le semblait le
suggérer
il ya deux phénomènes d'abord et even de
montée de la violence
il y à une multiplication des agressions
depuis dix ans tout le monde le sait
bien d'ailleurs depuis le début des
années 1970 il y a eu une aggravation
des agressions de toutes sortes
cela inquiète les français c'est un
véritable défi qui nous est lancé que
nous devons relever et cette montée de
la violence a coïncidé avec une sorte de
déviations et les remises de peine les
permissions de sortie les réductions de
peine de toutes sortes des libérations
conditionnelles qui jadis était défaveur
peu à peu son devenu comme un droit qui
est donné à tout le monde alors c'est
cette déviation contre laquelle il faut
lutter de même les sursis à l'origine le
sursis était une promesse et une menace
une promesse que si l'on ne
recommencerai pas la peine serait
effacée mais une menace si l'on
récidivait la peine tomberez on devrait
à faire et bien maintenant le sursis
automatiquement est oubliée c'est comme
si l'on n'avait rien eu de sorte que les
gangsters qui sont condamnés à une peine
avec sursis appel à la petite relaxe
ariel problème aussi de l'échelle les
peines et hélas les magistrats vous
reproche en gros ne pas leur faire
confiance ils pensent être le jus de ce
qui est bon ou mauvais pour un criminel
une chose pour les pour les jurés
d'assises il ya un principe fondamental
du droit français depuis 1789 c'est le
principe de la légalité des délits et
des peines cela veut dire quoi
cela veut dire
que les magistrats les juges doivent se
soumettre à la loi
les peines ne les ai dicté pas suivant
la fantaisie il les ai dicté en fonction
de la loi qui leur ont enjoint de
d'édicter telle et telle peine et pas
telle autre
c'est un principe fondamental de la
république elle est un président qui à
presque 200 deux ans d'âge et qui s'est
substitué à l'ancien régime et à
l'arbitraire total qui disait du fait
que le juge n'avait aucune limite
oui bon après si on peut moduler en
fonction la personnalité d'un criminel
en fonction du délai lui même tenue que
je serai de mon herbe qui dit que votre
projet est un véritable étouffoir des
libertés collectives et est d'abord
syndical si d'un exemple dykan incendies
de pneus sur la voie publique
vaud dans votre nouveau projet cinq ans
de prison minimum c'est gros non non
c'est pas vrai du tout il le thème la
teneur de l'article 434 du code pénal et
cloutés sa son père type écoute ce que
ça va ça du tout en réalité nous avons
resserré
l'éventail des peines qui jusqu'à
maintenant est tellement étendu que ils
allaient de zéro à l'infini
par exemple pour un même crime
on pouvait être coordonnées ou bien à
mort ou bien à trois ans avec sursis
c'est à dire rien du tout comme je viens
de vous l'expliquer tout à l'heure nous
resserrons l'éventail c'est à dire que
les juges seront guidés en quelque sorte
mais on leur imposera pas une décision
ils ont encore une grande liberté en
fonction de la personnalité mais cette
liberté est tout de même restreinte
c'est le principe de la légalité des
peines ils doivent se soumettre à la loi
les magistrats ne font pas la loi ils
l'appliquent
ce sont les députés les sénateurs les
représentants de la souveraineté
nationale qui font la loi et ils la font
librement
c'est que dans ce pays on est toujours
assez soucieux des libertés un certain
nombre de gens sont en train de se poser
des questions dont yann les réflexions
pour les étudiants étrangers on l'a vu
tout à l'heure avec raymond barre il ya
le problème du contrôle les avocats
dans les prisons le portique et les gens
se demandent si le libéralisme n'est pas
en train de se muscler et de notre
projet sécurité et liberté est un projet
très équilibré il faut qu'il soit
équilibré parce que la justice était qui
livre elle doit l'être l'image de la
justice et une balance et de plateaux il
faut que les deux plateaux soir à
hauteur égale il ya le plateau sécurité
dont nous venons de parler il ya le
plateau liberté plateau liberté nous
apportons si liberté nouvelle aux
français si liberté qu'aucun régime
français dans le passé n'avait accordé
aux français et même n'avait imaginé de
la raccorder je ne les ai ne mettrait
pas tous les six nous n'avons pas le
temps je vous citerai simplement deux
droits qui vont être garanti aux
français le premier droit c'est le droit
de la victime
jusqu'à maintenant on se soucie beaucoup
du criminel
on ne se soucie pas de la victime ans
occupe la tête et bien cette loi fera
respecter les droits des victimes
ça casse un nouveau l'an prochain et
d'autres pas avait encore failli le
faire
et d'autre part nous allons donner aux
français un droit nouveau c'est celui de
ne pas croupir des années en prison
à l'heure actuelle savez vous combien
nous avons deux prisonniers qui ne sont
pas encore jugés qui sont en détention
provisoire qui donc son suivant le code
présumé innocent nous en avons 18 milles
sur trente neuf mille prisonniers au
total près de la moitié de nos
prisonniers sont des innocents ou
présumés tels l'anglais l'accélérer
lajus et nous allons accélérer la
justice nous allons faire en sorte que
cette détention provisoire soit une
exception ils soient réduites au strict
minimum
un dernier mot je garde qui dépasse un
petit peu le propos de l'instant mais
mais qui a été évoqué en séance plénière
à l'assemblée nationale en commission
des lois la peine de mort
un débat toujours repoussée et
semble-t-il mais après les
présidentielles vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure devant groupe rpr
est ce que vous attendez que les jurés
fasse le travail pour vous
avec abolitionnistes non simplement j'ai
constaté une chose c'est que depuis
septembre 1977 et depuis bientôt trois
ans il n'y a eu en france aucune
exécution capitale ni même aucune
condamnation à mort à titre définitif et
par conséquent ce n'est pas un problème
immédiat qui se pose le problème
immédiat c'est celui dont nous avons
parlé c'est la sécurité des français
il faut que les français sentent que le
gouvernement fait ce qu'il faut pour ne
pas encourager les criminels à la
récidive pour lutter contre l'impunité
car l'impunité parmi tous les facteurs
du crime est le facteur le plus puissant
de crime merci à l'adversité et bien
tenez voilà un exemple de grande
criminalité jugé aujourd'hui en assises
l'avocat général a demandé la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité contre stéphane
dion des quatre là les accusés du procès
dit des tueurs de l'ardèche
verdict dans la soirée tout de suite le
compte rendu d'audience de claude
sérillon
ce fut un procès excessif excessif selon
le mot utilisé par au cours de sa
plaidoirie remarquable et ceux de sa
démonstration pertinentes et argumentée
par un avocat de la défense un avocat du
barreau d'avignon m bon enfant
car enfin qui est le tueur qui a tué
froidement un gendarme et deux
apiculteurs ardéchois c'est conti paviot
p4 clame le défenseur excessif parce
qu'à force de répéter qu'il y a un grand
absent conti il se produisait un
transfert de culpabilité survie au p4 le
présent excessif et agaçant aussi sept
accusés gp4 qu'il n'a plus que des
souvenirs sélectif et qui répond à
chaque question avec une application
tout scolaire non monsieur le président
je n'en ai plus le souvenir auditifs
excessif ce climat autour du procès où
l'on voit un témoin s'en prendre
directement aux défenseurs où l'on
aperçoit un magistrat un procureur
gesticuler derrière un avocat encourt de
paix doit riz comme s'il s'agissait d'en
rire excessif en face public venu
assister à la condamnation des tueurs de
l'ardèche est dépité par l'image des
deux accusés deux petits fils de famille
pitoyable est bien loin de l'image
terrifiante des meurtriers annoncé
sociale une journée revendicative
professions du spectacle une
manifestation de quelques 4000 artistes
du théâtre et d'audiovisuel à l'appel de
la cgt de plusieurs syndicats pour
protester le site contre le bradage des
activités culturelles
le bilan du troisième pacte pour
l'emploi or au terme d'un an de
fonctions objectif atteint dit le
président du cnt m
quatre cent vingt mille jeunes ont
trouvé une place quatre cent mille
autres emplois devraient être pourvus au
cours d'une seconde phase qui commence
dès maintenant
françois ceyrac a lancé un appel aux
chefs d'entreprises afin de débloquer
maximum d'offres d'emploi pour les
jeunes avant les vacances d'été
et puis demain journée d'action des
médecins opposés à la convention que
leur propose la sécurité sociale la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français appellent à une grève 24 heures
la cgt la cfdt et la fep organiseront
leur côté des manifestations alors
martine allard aux gnocchis va fermer
demain et pourquoi d'abord je ne sais
pas qui va fermer je peux dire qu'ils
vont répondre à l'appel
non seulement de la confédération mais
d'un certain nombre de petits syndicats
considérés comme la gauche médical qui
s'associent au mouvement
ce sont les médecins syndiqués ou pas
qui sont mécontents de la convention et
qui espère faire pression à la veille de
la signature est ce que c'est un baroud
d'honneur si finalement la convention
rétine je pense qu'elle sera malgré tout
fini sans doute la semaine prochaine
avec le seul syndicat minoritaire
représentatif celui de la fédération des
médecins de france
alors sitôt la convention signée car je
pense qu'elle le sera tout peut arriver
les médecins auront un mois pour se
situer dans la nouvelle convention ou or
la convention
alors parlons maintenant ce qui était
directement les malades
disons l'ensemble des assurés sociaux
c'est le poste où bhl secteur et oui
c'est où se situer dans la convention
pour un médecin alors j'ai pris un
exemple 5 uniquement celui de la
consultation du généraliste au prix de
base
alors si le médecin l'enfant le des
médecins se met dans le tarif des
honoraires fixes vous paierez 50 francs
quand vous irez sur les médecins
généralistes vous serez remboursé 37
francs vous débourserait à la forteresse
si votre médecin habituel a choisi de
faire partie du secteur libre vous
paierez selon son bon vouloir
60 70 80 90 francs vous serez toujours
remboursé 37 francs vous aurez à
débourser selon les cas si je ne trompe
pas vingt enfants 33 43 53 ou plus
lorsque vous dites alors alors je veux
quand même vous dire en quoi c'est que
là dessus il y a à peu près 4 francs qui
normalement devrait être à la charge du
médecin puisqu'il n'aura pile avantages
sociaux et des avantages fiscaux
mais ils seront récupérés dans le prix
des le barème de 60 francs
autrement dit l'assuré social va à
débourser pour le pouvoir d'achat et
pour les avantages sociaux du médecin à
la place du médecin et de la sécurité
sociale c'est lui le gruger vous met à
lire votre tableau l'aîné s'arrêtant
d'intérêt alors il ya naturel c'est que
vous savez il ya beaucoup trop de
médecins et la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie compte sur ce seul
fait pour freiner alors le syndicat qui
signent dit il n'y aura que 10 pers 10%
les médecins qui choisiront ce secteur
libre et la convention fonctionnera ce
qui ne signe pas 10
il y aura au moins 30% et la convention
va éclater nous ne voulons pas signer
cette convention
alors quelle heure actuelle il ya un
tout petit nombre de médecins ici ont
droit à des placements environ 15% alors
là il faut attendre deux mois pour le
savoir bien martine ernoux vous restez
avec nous pour ce sujet qui vous
intéresse au premier chef c'est le
troisième volet de notre grande enquête
sur le trafic du sang dans le monde
après le brésil et l'autriche philippe
gassot et et pierre moscovici ont
enquêté en france ici et l'achat de
produits sanguins est strictement
interdit tout le système est fondé sur
le bénévolat mais pour autant tous les
problèmes ne sont pas réglés
voilà
sans la main c'est relativement
pourquoi donner votre sang ce que je
pense que ça peut servir à d'autres est
peut-être moins juin
éventuellement
il est monsieur vincent bénévolement
pour aider la science et la médecine a
souri visuel les enfants et puis je le
fais aussi en hommage au docteur au feu
de faire là bas qui opérait la fille il
ya déjà une quinzaine d'années et depuis
je le fais en remerciement pour lui mais
doit-on acheter le sens la question est
toujours d'actualité
êtes vous choqué par les gens qui
vendent leur sang est plus choquant
c'est les gens qui ne donne pas alors
qu'ils sont capables de supporter
physiquement ça c'est beaucoup plus
choquant que ne veut pas payer ou du non
pas le faire payer les centres mobiles
de collecte sont devenus indispensables
ils font partie de l'environnement
habituel et il est courant de voir des
bénévoles venir à l'heure de la pause ou
en revenant du marché
est-ce qu'il arrive fréquemment que les
gens viennent nous voir pour gagner de
l'argent
gérard ceram et sur le passage ça arrive
ils nous demandent combien payez-vous
quand on leur dit rien il
generali vous dit bye bye à 112 et
français arrive à des français
son budget 30 actuellement
l'auteur y at il un dénominateur commun
jours les gens qui donnent leur sang je
pense que là cette expérience que j'ai
de la transfusion sanguine
c'est que le gunner du sang est un est
une personne qui ne
le plus souvent à la volonté de rendre
service et que
très peu de gens environ je viens pour
manger bien pour parce que j'ai envie de
donner mon sang et ça me soulage c'est
surtout par la volonté de rendre service
les personnes sans carte susceptible de
donner sans contrôle sont refusés
qu'est ce que vous venez faire la danse
de lyon un site où venait faire dans le
cadre mais ma carte je n'ai pas eu une
carte de quoi mettre de l'argent parce
que le bénévolat vous semble être la
bonne solution
le bénévolat est certainement une bonne
solution sur le plan national dans la
mesure où c'est la seule façon qu un
pays donné soit autonome sur le plan de
ses ressources sanguine
pourrait-on faire en france une
meilleure utilisation du sentier donner
sang total c'est à dire la l'ensemble
des éléments du sang ne devrait être
utilisé que dans un relativement petit
nombre d'indications ce qui n'est
malheureusement pas toujours le cas
qu'il ya une certaine partie du plasma
qui pourraient être utilisés pour faire
d'autres dérivés du sang qui ne sont pas
utilisées de façon tout à fait optimum
certains de vos confrères parle de
gâchis
il est difficile de parler actuellement
de gâchis mais il est certain que le
sang total à une limite de péremption
qui ne peut être conservé pendant un
certain temps et que occasionnellement
le sang total en particulier peut
dépasser cette limite de péremption et
par conséquent ne peut pas être utilisé
il y a du sens perdue ou mal utilisé les
donneurs eux-mêmes le dénonce le
secrétaire général pour le développement
de la transfusion a déclaré devant le
ministre de la santé quand 78 sur 4
millions de flacons prélever un million
deux cent mille n'ont jamais été
utilisés chiffre énorme qu'il faudra
prouver mais qui indique clairement un
malaise
oui charles mérieux le directeur de la
fondation du même nom a été très
critiqué par les milieux médicaux
français pour avoir traité le sang
humain comme un vulgaire produit
industriel
depuis trois ans les banques de sang
meirieu ont été fermés en france et
l'institut installer une filiale aux
états unis
ce que vous ne pouvez pas faire en
france vous le faites aux états unis aux
etats unis c'était légal je ne s'aperçut
que parce que à l'heure actuelle faut
bien dire que je ne crois pas que le
trafic du sang non par le temps au
brésil ailleurs chances sont réelles
un rallye
le bond entier est approvisionnée par du
sang américain
prélevez régulièrement mais avec des
intermédiaires véreux
alors autant ce commerce opérant cible
autant la douce américaine est
respectable
alors docteur je reviendrai sur la
législation française on ne vous permet
pas de fabriquer du facteur 8 en france
vous allez le fabriqué aux états unis ce
facteur 8 revient en france
alors ça rime à quoi pourquoi les
français ne peuvent pas faire ce facteur
vite mais juste un bel avant goût
je crois que je croque oui je pense tout
produire aidé la france à faire des
affaires et à faire des produits
industriels non mieux ebitda gaspillage
nous on fait un essai aux ats-unis
malheureux jeudi malgré tout prévu sauf
que d'après d'autres métiers que vous
existez toujours à miami pour fraudes
existent pour faire c'est une tentative
c'était normal nous sommes devenus
illégaux en france
nous avons essayé de travailler dans un
pays où vous êtes et les cas nous avons
vu les inconvénients
je ne peux cacher du tout non mais je
n'y peux vous en cachez mais vous
utiliser les mêmes armes que les
personnes que l'on trouve répréhensible
en france ou à l'étranger non parce que
le plasma américain prélevait pas sous
contrôle de l'autorité américaine et au
trafic tôt quand on parle de 100
jamaïcain au brésilien c'est possible je
ne prends pas que ça existe ou très peu
enfin on prélève du sang des gens qui
ont besoin de levante donc qu'ils ont
besoin d'argent lors de l'essai pour
fabriquer des produits qui sont vendus
plus chers des gens qui ont de l'argent
ces déchets américaine mais les bars les
marges fin pour d'autres les marchés
sont négatives et autant vous dire qu'on
n'a pas réussi bataille allemand vous
n'êtes pas choquer moralement par ces
procédés tu as fais tout à fait choquant
vous ne le ferez plus bas non non non
aux états unis dont nous avons fait deux
tentatives et nous essayons d'y mettre
fin l'insurrection en corée du sud
maintenant après l'arrestation samedi
dernier de l'un des principaux chefs de
l'opposition
la population et plus particulièrement
les étudiants d'une vingtaine de villes
sont en évolution
apprendre bio c'est à dire à 350 km au
sud ouest de séoul
les insurgés se sont emparés des dépôts
d'armes de l'armée et se trouve
maintenant mettre de la ville après
avoir récupéré comme vous l'avez vu des
blindés ce soir cette ville est coupée
de l'extérieur et l'armée a installé un
siège en règle
en quatre jours les émeutes ont fait
plusieurs dizaines de morts à travers le
pays et plus de 2000 blessés
sport tennis huitièmes de finale des
internationaux d'italie yannick noah
faciles vainqueurs des dips sera le seul
français en quarts de finale en effet
thierry tulasne n'a pas renouvelé son
exploit d'hier on n'y a pourtant presque
cru pendant deux heures mais il a été
finalement battu par le tchèque tomas
semé après avoir remporté le premier set
6 à rome victor hommes
premier set thierry tulasne commence le
match en grande forme
il joue vite et bien ses coups droits
mais surtout ces revers sont puissants
et précis le tchécoslovaque smit qui est
l'un des 20 meilleurs joueurs du monde
sur terre battue ce mythe ne fait pas le
poids
6 jeux à 1 en faveur de tulane tous les
espoirs sont permis et personne
n'imagine que le petit français va
perdre par la suite les deuxième et
troisième sets contre smid
aujourd'hui j'ai très bien commencé le
match est gagné 6 1 2 0 et 1 à mon
entraîneur m'a dit je ne suis pas rendu
compte sur le moment je prenais passer
mon temps entre les points
et j'ai commencé à fatiguer à partir de
2 partout comment senti une fatigue est
là il a bien serré n'joy maintenant de
pression m'a fait droite gauche est bien
monté g
j'ai raté le coche à cinq partout cinq
cartons jaunes 4 6 1 mon service
enfin pierre troisième d'avoir mon
travail nous sommes au deuxième set et
tulasne est effectivement moins bien
placé par rapport à la balle il montre
une certaine faiblesse au filet et le
jeu de ce mythe consiste justement à
faire jouer le plus possible tulasne au
filet les coûts de tulasne sont moins
précis qu'au premier set deuxième set
donc 7 jeux à 5 en faveur de semide
troisième set 6 jeux à 1 en faveur de ce
mythe tulasne n'ira pas en quarts de
finale mais il a été adopté par le
public romain parce qu'il est le plus
jeune et parce que finalement il a très
bien joué
quelle est la suite maintenant de votre
programme à quelques compétitions vous
avez participé
je vais me consacrer à roland garros 1
semaine prochaine
compétition 80 importante pour moi parce
que en ce moment je joue très bien je
vais essayer de continuer la coupe davis
non non
alors finalement bon ben je pense que
vous êtes un peu amer mais enfin
on n'avait même pas 17 ans donc tout est
possible noah donc lui ira en quart de
finale contre barazutti il a battu la
main qu'un édit dips qui a abandonné au
second set après s'être plaint d'une
douleur à la cuisse
et puisque nous parlons de l'italie un
mot sur la 6e étape du giro si l'italien
baronne et qui l'a emporté bernard
hinault conserve le maillot rose eric
tabarly a déclaré forfait pour la
transat anglaise blessée à l'épaule aux
sports d'hiver il ne pouvait plus tenir
la barre de son trimaran à hydro folle
c'est vraiment la tuile parce que cette
transat au fond ce compte et je comptais
sur cette course au fond depuis depuis
des années on il a gagné pour la
troisième fois
bah j'aurais bien voulu en tout cas et
tout au moins j'aurai essayé mais cette
décision médicale est vraiment
irrémédiable irréversible la cia plus
d'espoir alors expliquez nous cet
accident tout de même bien je suis tombé
je suis tombé sur l'épaule fin février
et ont saisi en faisant du ski oui et
alors
au début ça m'a pas inquiété pendant
pendant un mois d'ailleurs ça
ça ne gênait pas beaucoup et puis au
bout d'un mois lors l'asl état empirait
vraiment et c'est à partir de ce moment
là que j'ai commencé à avoir des
médecins et
vous n'avez pas pensé à transgresser
leur avis quand même aux non non moi je
tiens absolument pas faire d' imprudence
un jeu c'est que il ya des mouvements
que je peux pour faire donc il ya des
manoeuvres que je pourrais pas faire ça
peut être ça peut être très dangereux je
peux soûles et sous l'effet de la
douleur parce que quelquefois quand tu
fais les mouvements qu'il faut pas faire
les la douleur est fulgurante donc ça
peut faire leurs chais ce que je tiens
ça peut donc je peux tomber à l'eau je
peux et puis non ça peut ce serait
prendre des risques vraiment dudit
inutile et trop pensez vous être prêts
pour la transat en double ah oui aux
bosses ça nous laisse un an là quand
même
en un an je serai rétabli à ce n'est
malheureusement pas joe n'a même pas le
droit de le remplacer à la barre
football dans quelques minutes au parc
des princes la finale du tournoi de
paris opposant le paris saint germain au
standard de liège le match pour la
troisième place vient de se terminer et
l'ajax d'amsterdam a été battu 5 1 par
benfica le tiercé et bien les voici les
résultats 1 4 14 pour 5 francs vous le
voyez dans l'ordre 7080 francs et dans
un ordre différent 1416 de francs la
météo est aujourd'hui les températures
sont restées très basses pour la saison
mais la région parisienne a bénéficié
d'un large soleil alors pour demain
laurent broomhead vos prévisions
m'écouter retour progressif du beau
temps d'abord sur le nord ensuite sur le
sud l'anticyclone qui est à l'ouest
c'est bien ma foi
cette zone de temps stable progresse
vers l'intérieur a par le nord de
l'europe est elle descendra ensuite vers
le sud
alors demain une france coupée en deux
sur la moitié sud donc des brumes
beaucoup de nuages encore le matin d
hitler si tout de même ensuite mais
encore de nombreuses averses orageuses
en particulier dans les régions
méditerranéennes et en corse puis sur la
moitié nord un temps en général
ensoleillé avec simplement quelques
passages de nuages mais attention les
températures seront très nettement plus
fraîches le matin par plus de 5 degrés
environ de la flandre à l'alsace et
jusqu'au bassin parisien
et pour ce prix vous nous laissez le
sommeil le soleil oui je laisse le
soleil et je retire les nuages en effet
le beau temps va progresser vers le sud
encore des orages dans l'extrême sud est
le sud des alpes et la corse partout
ailleurs une amélioration de la brume le
matin du soleil ensuite des températures
qui monteront dans l'après-midi de 16
degrés au nord
à 20 degrés environ au dessus donc fera
pas extrêmement chaud y fera toujours
extrêmement frais voire froid le matin
ça c'est pour samedi dimanche
théoriquement le beau temps stable
d'anticyclone avec du ciel bleu devrait
continuer et on va me diriez vous si
tout va bien lundi avant sans doute
l'arrivée de pluie par le nord ouest
lundi soir voilà c'est à long terme
vous avez rendez vous avec pierre-alain
pour le dernier journal vers 23h35
celui-ci tout à fait terminé bonsoir à
tous adnan à terre à